clientélisme électoral ça on va
l'écarter parce que c'est l'opportunisme
du cynisme mais ça n'a pas de deux de
charpente idéologique en revanche ce
qu'on appelle l'islamo gauchisme a pas
été théorisée parce que personne c'est
revendiquer islamo gauchiste mais c'est
un certain nombre de textes qui rejoint
exactement ce que vous dites et qui
résonne de la façon suivante qui se
disent c'est des marxistes qui se disent
de nouveaux damnés de la terre de
nouveau prolétariat est incarnée par les
musulmans et les musulmans sont opprimés
par les ennemis permanent du prolétariat
qui sont le capitalisme incarné en
général par les américains et israël et
la religion chrétienne est donc l'islamo
gauchisme ça c'est jacques julia ce que
je vous dis qu'il a écrit dans le figaro
dans son carnet qu'il tient et qui la
décrit de façon très très abouti à ces
trois ennemis là que je viens de nommer
et pense que le enfin les musulmans vont
permettre de vaincre l'ennemi absolu qui
est le grand capital et le capitalisme
et donc il y a des pensées aux france à
edwy plenel des journalistes ou même
emmanuel todd qui dans son livre qui est
charlie avait développé cette idée
l'idée de ce nouveau prolétariat
qui est un pro l'état de se concentrer
je pense même pas que c'est par
bienveillance vis-à-vis des musulmans
mais c'est comme une arme que l'on
utiliserait puisque les armes
précédentes n'ont pas n'ont pas été
suffisamment efficace
manuel valls oui mais ça a été une des
lignes de fracture ben oui oui parce que
ça si vous voulez y avait enfin on l'a
bien vu sous quinquennat de françois
hollande il y avait l'idée que forcément
le musulman où l'immigré musulman est
une victime et ne peut pas être un
agresseur et qu'il est toujours la
victime d'une société qui te société
patriarcale atteinte chrétienne
pro-américaine capitaliste est donc ce
cette grille de lecture à mon avis
aveugle et un certain nombre de gens
peut-être certains très sincèrement et
et les a entraînés dans cette sincérité
je ne sais pas on peut pas juger moi je
suis pas là pour sonder des reins et les
coeurs mais il ya en tout cas d'une
cohérence idéologique dans ce sens qu'on
appelle l'islamo gauchisme